so what I'm introducing here why why do
we go to the bother of I'm getting
second derivative it's not just that
these points of inflection which I'll
get to you in more detail a second but
it's also an alternative way of
determining the nature of a station
important and you need to know both okay
you need to know I can test the first
derivative to the left and to the right
okay or you can use the second
derivative okay let me give you a quick
example of why you might use one and not
the other let's consider a function like
this
okay I don't know what this looks like
yes anyway right but I do already know
that if I were to differentiate this
okay you know say the question was find
the stationary points and determine
their nature
okay obviously you have two different
chain wants so you say well that equals
and this is question rule right so let's
just go through it quickly this is going
to be U and this is V so to move on V
squared right that's what a question
rule is so there's the first fitting and
you - it just one and then you looks
like that and V - requires chain rule
right so what's this gonna be
it looks like bring the three on the
front X cubed okay that's the numerator
that's the booth part and now I need
this that Square will be six right okay
now I can tidy this up in a minute
right and then I'll have to solve that
and find my stationary points okay but
you can see in this case if I want to
determine the nature of the stationary
points and I've got two ways to do it I
can test the first derivative on either
side or I can test the second derivative
at those particular locations which
would you prefer and why first three
video or second derivative I'd go in
first right here's why even though first
is like man okay test values on either
side that's a pain well guess what else
is a pain differentiating this again
right it already gotten to a this is why
we don't like push it all right it
steady into an awful mess just
differentiating it's okay let's just for
the sake of it okay so you can get a
sense of how bad it is and why you
should always use the second derivative
okay
that's tidy this up a little I still got
this cubed minus 9x squared X minus 1 X
cubed plus 2 squared
or but that okay you want me to
factorize that into there I think that's
going back to us isn't it oh yeah I can
RI fine director 9x that's going to be 9
X cubed minus 9x squared how do you want
like that okay let's get the now I could
actually I can do a little bit all right
cuz can you see there's a big common
factor going around there's an X cubed
plus 2 that there's quite a few of them
right this 3 here was true there and
there's six here okay so let's be a
little bit up I can get rid of two from
all of them okay so that leave me with
one here and this guy yeah I'm gonna
take the nine apples ton of makeup and
since I got rid of the true this should
become four okay that's that's better
that's better
I could I could okay I've got some cubes
here all right so I can simplify that
it's reduced we do that X cubed minus 9x
kids is minus a X cubed plus 9x squared
plus two yeah X cubed plus 4 okay I
think I'm really differentiate all right
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go up here who's
a coconut butter I'm looking about the
simplifying after my first line cuz
you'll see why he's the second
derivative move on V squared V is X
cubed plus 2 to the for you - is minus
24x squared plus 18x that's not that's
bu - - you
you last night it's you know this points
where you like seemed like a good idea
at the time
V - okay okay I'm going to the four and
the three x squared together so that's
going to be 12x squared and then I have
to reduce the power by 1 which is X cube
plus 2 cubed yes
and then that is over X cubed plus 2 so
the height then okay yeah why did I
differentiate again then you have to
solve where you can actually evaluate
this thing where you find your
stationary points okay so the second
derivative can be useful if in this kind
of case right the more you differentiate
look I started here and then I
differentiate it once and then
differentiate it again so the more you
differentiate the simpler the function
gets but other functions you start here
and then you go to here and then you end
up with this mess so you differentiate
it gets worse and worse and worse
okay basically okay but there's more
varieties like that this is lovely this
is not the only kind but that's one of
them okay
so it's how to determine the nature of
stationary point using the second